hello and welcome to this video play
Thresh massive snake I know name okay
and the one time you go t four instead
of lighter three they play the room for
the other exact opening lets you plan to
avoid with your moves and he will play
we should be six the line way I have
nothing against problem nope this is not
a big issue it's taking a long time when
the issue is that I have forgotten how
this works but position wise I'm fine
young knight a six valid it's not really
good I don't think this is enough
compensation but like before I think
it's blacks idea I'm not entirely sure
about how you continue from here it
should be five or something
ninety force and it is it is an annoying
move through this it's a bit funny bit
want to be ready to trade off the bishop
maybe e6 or something like that
94
set the ID probably
and 92 looks extremely slow is my issue
same as f3 Queen d2 whether that will
prevent 94 maybe it is tricky to play
still
mm-hm well I've done something wrong not
quite sure what but something went wrong
here threatens night xt5 now I need to
develop stuff I cannot play something
slow now I don't think so 95 Bishop g7
King g7 mmm well it's still okay I don't
think he can play 95 straight away at
least at the end he's got some problem
with the repent right there 95 percent
yourself King G 795 2290 255 reform
should win material but he can claim I
know II 6 or maybe Bishop e6 yeah I
thought that doesn't work ok so let's
just play the line that I had seen I
mean I don't see why not
how does he say that this is I'm in the
material here I really do efore wookie
5f4 h5 Bishop e2 he will drop the night
at the end or he has to give the
exchange somehow that's exactly the line
that I had seen check ok
so much for I'm winning material
I gave it I think maybe maybe I have a
little something I can probably play
with d7 studies with placing the roof I
think while just goes a five a four no
matter what
maybe for 95
yeah
that's probably okay for him I want to
know I can push this back I don't think
he has enough compensation if he sex
like sign warning and this is actually
like for white this position
[Music]
I'm 95 at the end just got no good
square em would be success 97 it's a
piece
they're just a piece of lack realize
okay so let's have a look there a couple
of things that are really left leg clear
yeah I don't think this is a concept for
us and don't think it's enough but I
forgot why definitely this looks a
little bit slow and he definitely was
okay in the game so probably something
else Bishop c4 is indicated by the
computer yeah I mean it makes some sense
yeah to use this and maybe also have
night GE - yeah I don't think it's
ultimately enough yeah that was okay
though for black but yeah I think he
should avoid this I mean even though I
miscalculated the line and I think this
is a little bit better still maybe
I'm sorry yet is what to say yet it I
thought you should go here and then play
b6 Bishop a6 and this is in fact okay if
I miss I mean I'm a little bit quicker
if we if we check this want this yeah
I'm a little bit quicker on the central
files over this King a bit less active
but the engine indicates equal so
probably there's nothing so rather be
Wyatt but still yet here I think
something is wrong my f1 came I probably
it was a bad idea to withdraw the route
we through and it didn't work well II
don't hear the material was gone so
somewhere around here he has to defend
better probably five is wrong the pawn
on e5 is in is immediately week and
there are some technical issues on top
of it this is probably probably the
point okay guys thanks for watching